this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you very much and thank you Sarah
for for hosting and thanks all of you
for for hosting to me coming back to
Ithaca coming to Cornell has a has a has
a bit of a nostalgia as a graduate
student at NC State I used to be I used
to come to Cornell very very often her
and have spent a lot of time in these
buildings so it's great great to be back
and especially for your hospitality and
for organizing such a wonderful weather
huh that that suits so well to my Indian
skin so thank you very much great to be
great to be here I wanted to sort of
start with um if this if I know how to
operate this I wanted to start with her
with a small story that many of you may
have heard this is this is a story from
maybe I don't know 1,500 years ago when
there were no televisions it feels like
1,500 years ago there were no television
said no radios and no media and people
were pretty siloed in their little
countries where ever they were and in in
in those days something like this and
any more like this landed let's say here
in Ithaca where nobody had ever seen an
elephant before so people started
looking at this huge big thing that came
and landed here in Ithaca and different
people had different interpretation
about and describing this this whole
animal people who saw it from the top
thought it was a fan people who saw it
from from the tail side thought it was a
rope people some people thought it was a
it was a pole some people who saw it
from that side thought it was a big huge
pipe the biggest problem is that you
know different people had different
views in identifying this thing and
different people had different
interpretation
of what this this whole thing was the
biggest challenge was that they did not
see it in a holistic way and looked at
the elephant as an elephant and they did
not recognize that I think you know we
all would agree that a lot of the work
that we do in agriculture right now is
is pretty similar we we look at it from
many many different angles you know the
people in the private sector for example
you know from a vantage point of one of
the fastest growing business in the
world if we look at the seed industry
for example you know we know why these
large modules are happening these days
and last week for example one of the
largest merger there is tremendous
potential in the private sector in the
way agriculture is growing for example
as a business proposition if you look at
the seed industries for example which is
at about what I think about fifty three
billion right now is is in five years
projected to be at about ninety three
point six billion dollars and and all
this growth is is mainly going to come
from developing countries and so if we
look at the private sector angle they
look at it from from a huge business
opportunity perspective if you look at
the large NGO and CSO sectors which is
very very active in agriculture in
developing countries they look at it
more from a rural development angle
because the large number of rural people
whom these NGOs and cso's work with also
happen to be farmers so if you are doing
health work in rural area if you are
doing you know social benefit work in
rural area agriculture becomes very
important as well and therefore you know
often it is seen from that angle if you
look at from the public sector or the
government perspective of that of course
policies and and so forth but let's face
is one of the biggest thing is you know
a large portion of their voters also
happen to be people who are dependent on
AG
culture so you know from a political
angle also you and from a food security
angle this becomes an extremely
important proposition if we look at the
the elections around the world in last
four years which is recent elections in
in many countries 57 countries have had
agriculture as their main issue of
elections and this again is because of
the dependence of a large number of
people in these countries on agriculture
and therefore agriculture becomes a
major major agenda for the for the
political parties as well from an R&D
perspective of course you know there are
large number of challenges to be
addressed and and especially and I'll
talk about that little more especially
increasing productivity and so forth so
there is a there is a different angle
but if you look at the farmers
especially in the developing country
farmers the way they look at agriculture
and and contrary to a lot of the
government's event believing you know I
i always say farmers don't form because
they are concerned about country's food
security farmers farm because they see
this as a business and often a lot of
these people especially CSO public
sector and often R&D angle sort of
forgets that angle that the farmer looks
at it for a former it is marketable
product that they are interested in they
are really not interested in in anything
else right and farmers around the world
you know grow it as a as an important
source of their livelihood often and
only source of their livelihood and and
we also know from from a large number of
studies that most of the developing
current country farmers remain in
agriculture because they don't have any
other option and therefore the efforts
that we we do in through any of these
stakeholders will have to keep that in
mind
so I just wanted to and I wanted to do
it more as a discussion point because I
know there is a there is a there is a
lot of knowledge in this room as well so
I wanted to sort of as much as I can
open this up and talk about these issues
but one of the things I wanted to talk
about is taking India as an example and
just taking an overview of of Indian
agriculture where it stands right now
and what are the key challenges from all
these different perspectives and and and
then looking at productivity I was
tempted to bring this because Sarah told
me this is going to be a plant breeding
and genetic seminar and therefore I
wanted to bring an on productivity angle
to the to the seminar and 22 again talk
about more from a client perspective
from a farmer's perspective and then I
want to you know summing up all these
ideas that we've been thinking about we
have completely sort of revamped our
agricultural investment strategy as bill
and melinda gates foundation especially
for india and we'd like to talk a little
bit about about that and what are our
focus areas and how it has shifted kind
of to respond to some of these these big
changes that i will talk about
throughout the slides so you know india
is about to become the most populated
country agriculture continues to to
remain a backbone of india's economy
despite of the the large growth
throughout the country has moved to a
mode at the is moving at the pace of say
seven percent 7.5 percent economic
growth agriculture remains at about 2.5
2.8 and yet because of the large number
of people dependent on agriculture the
rural economies of india continues to
remain very very dependent on on
agriculture and this is this is not very
different from many other developing
countries but in the
it is it is it is really unique because
if you look at look at generally the
history as as the country progresses the
farm sizes have increased in many many
countries around the world we have seen
it in India for some reason we are not
seeing that phenomenon in last 40 years
the the farm size or the landholding has
actually haft from 2.3 to about 1.2 now
so it is it is going to continue for
quite some time as an low input low
output agriculture system but the
numbers that it has you know one-fourth
of the of the world's farming population
lives in India so so if you say every
every fourth farmer in the world is an
Indian farmer so a large number of
farming population large number of
people people dependent on agriculture
as an important or only source of their
livelihood is what is making making it
unique the other unique feature about
India and that's again something that we
will have to remember while while
designing our research programs or while
designing our policies is the prevalence
of mixed farming system there is no such
thing as crop farmer or livestock farmer
in a country like India it is all mixed
farming farmers do it mainly as their
mitigation risk mitigation strategy but
if you look at a typical average Indian
farm and and you know this is something
I constantly remind my colleagues at the
foundation also that you know anything
we say about India you know the opposite
view also could be true so it is very
difficult to generalize anything about
this country however generally speaking
on an average it is all mixed farming
system where there is typically a 1.2
hectares of land and one livestock it is
it could be a cow it could be a buffalo
or it could be
the average is 2.2 goats so this is this
is the kind of mixed farming and
therefore when you look at it from a
farmer's perspective the farmer is not
looking for a crop solution or a
livestock solution the farmer is looking
for a combined solution and a large
number of our R&D efforts a large number
of our policy effort kind of misses out
on that that vantage point and I'll talk
a little bit more about that little
little bit the GDP growth so it's it's
very interesting that as I said they the
country's agriculture is growing at the
rate of about 2.5 two-point-eight
percent the countries generally economic
growth is at has crossed about seven
percent and and therefore the demand for
food is increasing and and and with the
demand and with the income the kind of
food people are asking for the diversity
is increasing let me take you I take an
example of livestock for example for
over the years India itself India's
policymaking itself and India and and
the international perception about the
country was that this is predominantly a
vegetarian country and that's why the
livestock sector is not growing the the
income levels changing has completely
proven us wrong in that perception the
livestock sector growth for example in
the country is has doubled then then the
general agricultural growth and the
demand for meat in the country has
increased at the rate of eight to twelve
percent in last last last five years
depending upon which state so people
were not predominantly vegetarian
because of any religious biases larger
number of people were vegetarian because
they could not afford non-vegetarian
food so now with those income level
rising there is a big demand in in in
that also and the demand went up to a
level where for example since last three
years now India became the world's large
exporter of meat for a contrary to the
belief that this is a vegetarian country
you know that entire thing has has
shifted as well very little land the
last point very little land very little
agricultural resources like water but a
large population which is growing and
also a very large number of worlds 15%
livestock that that little land and that
water has to support so these are these
these are some of the opportunities and
some of the challenges that one has to
work with so as you can see the
dependence on agriculture in the country
you know if we look at compare it with
China for example the dependence on
agriculture has been reducing however in
India that is that has not made a major
major change it is slowly decreasing but
still extremely important where more
than half of the country's population
depends on agriculture if you compare it
say for example with with some of these
countries you can see why from a policy
perspective from a politician's
perspective from a private sector angle
from all these NGOs here so why would a
Greek ulch ER means so much not just
because of agriculture as farming but
because of the people who are dependent
on agriculture so over the years you
know given given all these population
challenges and all that also the country
has really come a long way in becoming
one of the one of the top agriculture
uses it is it is it's remarkable where
where it has come in terms of its it's
you know rice and wheat and vegetables
and pulses and all these production so
that there has been a remarkable
progress however I am reminded
especially because I'm standing in a
plant breeding and genetics department
that all these these large numbers and
all the
growth predominantly comes from the
large number of people it does not come
from productivity efficiency
productivity still remains at one of the
lowest in the world in in India so it is
it is just this this large numbers that
is driving this production and the
growth so while I would say that they
the production of India the output is
very very high I would not call the
Indian agriculture system as an
effective or sustainable center system
so I just wanted to take you know two
major areas where what what has driven
mainly those big data that you saw and
what has brought the country from two to
a level of being one of the leaders in
agricultural production but at the same
time I also wanted to visit two factors
that has that has been a challenge as
well for the country in which which we
which we continue to face and I
especially wanted to bring it because
you know a lot of the lot of other
countries especially countries in East
Africa and so forth are trying to take
these parts and there are a large number
of lessons that are hidden from the from
the India story so green revolution in
India as we know from from 60s to 90s
this was really truly a revolutionary
thing where the country's the you know
the wheat and rice production went up by
thirty percent it was it was really a
remarkable progress in terms of the food
production so you know in in 50s from
being uh you know they used to call it
ship to mouth country where the country
was dependent on agriculture import it
there was this was one huge policy
change the green revolution that brought
the country to do a food exporting state
so it was a remarkable progress it
and it was mainly you know through large
number of technology adoption it was
especially the seed technology adoption
and added with a large extension efforts
but but a very very public dominated
government dominated revolution that
that brought about that huge change that
you you see that that steep curve in the
graph then came the dairy revolution
which was about 40 years ago now where
where India became the largest producer
of milk in the world and this was again
a revolutionary thing in the livestock
sector but only in the cattle sector in
the in the dairy sector which again was
very very remarkable in and it had a
significant impact also on the
consumption pattern where people were
getting only about 100 and 11 grams per
day in 74 that went more than double by
by 2011 so it was a huge and despite of
the population growth so so the second
one was the was the white revolution
that brought about some of those numbers
as well but again in both these
revolutions the focus was the you know
production by masses rather than mass
production and that was the major
difference between an industrial country
you know bringing in that production
level high and and in this kind of a
country well bringing in a production
high productivity continues to remain a
major challenge and it's just the
numbers that is driving the whole thing
so if you if we if we look at the
comparison between Green Revolution and
white revolution and I want to open this
up at this point also and I just wanted
to bring a few pointers and wanted to
have some
some some brainstorming with with you
guys because I know some of you know
these stories very very well and I just
wanted to open up to talk about a little
more and is to comparing some of these
these revolutions but if we look at the
Green Revolution it was public sector
driven there is if you look at the White
Revolution it was far more cooperative
driven it was it was basically a
people's moment the White Revolution the
government of course was very very
involved but it wasn't dominated by the
policies or it wasn't the government
driven think Jeb I'm just coming from
from Sarah's program on on the Alliance
for sciences and I was thinking about
the third one which came up which was
the cotton growth story and some people
in India like to call it as the gene
revolution and if we look at that if you
look at that as a revolution if you look
at the the prevalence of transgenic
cotton in in a country like India if you
want to call it like a gene revolution
that was predominantly private sector
driven so it's so interesting in the
same kind of country in the same kind of
a format how different revolutions had
different impacts at different levels
and how all three were completely a
different approach a public sector led a
farmer led a people moment cooperative
lead and a completely private sector-led
revolution the Green Revolution was very
production centric right it was it was
only about you know increasing the
production come what may whatever it
takes let's just increase the production
of the country to be able to you know
come out of that that import dependence
so it was very very production centric
if we look at the milk revolution or the
white revolution it was market cedric
the the entire focus was on not on
production the entire focus was on
market
element you know let's give all these
large number of men and women especially
women a market base let us let us create
that market place where they can we can
aggregate their milk and they can sell
their milk and create that market base
everything else production animal health
all those things will will follow and so
it was a very market centric program
well when I say production centric in
Green Revolution market of course is
important but the buyer in those days
and buyer even now remains the
government which is the predominant
buyer of the green revolution products
from the farmer so the farmer did not
have to worry about market so it was
only the production aspect whereas here
it was market aspect both focused on
limited number of commodities you know
none of our green none of our
revolutions has been multi commodity
revolutions Green Revolution focused
only on 2 comma commodities mainly rice
and wheat milk revolution of course
focused only on milk and both
interestingly in a large country like
India focused on on a very very set
small area of geography the Green
Revolution focused only in three or four
states in the northern part of India it
did not worry about anything else the
white revolution focused only on two or
three states in the western part of
India and did not worry about anything
else so this would this were the two two
very very dynamic but you know two
revolutions same country completely
different approaches I can stop here for
a while and get some get some discussion
here yeah
so the so the White Revolution as I said
was a very grass root level level
program right where is the Green
Revolution I have a fascinating story
that my my professor who used to be very
associated with Cornell also MS
Swaminathan who worked with Norman
Borlaug to bring the Green Revolution to
India and dr. swaminathan tells a very
fantastic story where he says the then
Prime Minister of India indira gandhi
had come to a trip to the US and had
some meetings in Washington DC asking
the US government who was the main
supplier of of wheat to india in those
days to reduce the price further of what
they are sending to India and whatever
happened in that diplomatic meeting she
mrs. Gandhi came back to to India at six
o'clock in the morning and 8 30 she
called a meeting of her agriculture
minister and a few people and said
whatever is it takes I don't care for
anything else I don't care for
sustainability I don't care how many
people you need I want the food
production in this country to go up and
I am giving you 10 years for that and
this this is a story here so as an
extremely strong political will I think
was was under that but at the same time
an extreme need it was almost like a
crisis situation that that brought it
there and in the history of India this
is the first time the agriculture
scientist of the country the top
agricultural scientists of the country
were reporting directly to the Prime
Minister that's the kind of I think
political will it it it required but you
are you most welcome to add to this and
not just just ask so
why is the milk revolution so limited in
number positive because those areas of
the range or why no that's that's
exactly and that's that's what I wanted
to talk about when I say what did not
work and I think that it has been one of
the biggest challenges it has you know
we've paid a price for these revolutions
also and I wanted to wanted to briefly
talk about that also in the in the next
one so thanks for raising though yeah
right so the meat revolution again is is
just because of the large number of
cattles that that are sort of addressing
the the milk need and that's how it it
came in there is very little government
involvement really in that export market
it is it is all generally there are
several perceptions now with with some
of those religious biases of whether or
not we can export beef or not or whether
or whether or not we can actually kill a
cow or not but that is a different thing
India it is very interesting because you
know at least fifty eight percent of our
milk comes from buffaloes and not cows
so a large amount of meat that you see
getting exported is predominantly
buffalos so yeah
yeah that's that's one of the things and
also as I said you know Buffalo comp is
a is a very big part of the dairy sector
so it is it is both but any because I
know there has been several groups at
Cornell historically also involved in in
in some of these India's revolutions
anything you would like to add would be
would be great as well yeah
so it was public sector involvement in
green revolution as I said and far more
cooperative moment you know farmers
themselves aggregating together and and
doing this and making it world's largest
farmer cooperative moment was was behind
the behind the white revolution but
there was a lot of international the
technology played an extremely important
role also green revolution for example
now it's interesting because white
revolution was as I said was not
production driven it was market driven
so there were limited technology you
know facets as it began later on of
course as the farmer saw more value to
their markets they had more money to
spend on their cattle then the
vaccination started then the animal
health investment started and that was a
different story but but the genesis of
it but in case of Green Revolution the
dir ate rice variety for example the
draft wheat variety all those
technologies actually came with the with
the support of Ford Foundation and
Rockefeller Foundation and it was Norman
Borlaug who kind of brought those so
that was very very technology oriented
and with absolute international support
as far as the technology is is concerned
so I just wanted to briefly bring in and
sort of revisit both these revolution
and then connected to some of India's
modern-day agricultural problems and and
perhaps if with a threat of sounding you
know too abrupt connecting them with
some of the limitations that these
revolutions brought to the country to
your question Green Revolution had a
very very isolated impact it had huge
impact on those isolated areas and
therefore the country got a big win in
increasing its production and so forth
but it in those days it started in
isolation and to date today even after
all these years also we have not been
successful in bringing those
revolutionary productions both in case
of Green Revolution and invite
revolution to other parts of India which
actually you know needs it much more now
and and so if you can see and it had
impact on everything if you see the
agriculture technology adoption rate if
you look at the productivity angle so I
don't want to deny that productivity is
not a challenge it absolutely is a
challenge and especially in the
coexistence of different system in a
country like India where there are
different trajectories there is an there
is a very very high input high output
agriculture in the country also but
predominantly the country remains very
low input low output type agriculture
and there are major differences in
productivity within the state also so
the same rice variety for example the
the one of the most popular one the poo
sobriety in Punjab which was a green
revolution state would would would be
about 6.8 tons per hectare the same pusa
variety the same rice in in a place in
be
our for example would hardly bring in a
bring in a productivity of about 2.3 so
within the country there are huge
disparities in terms of productivity in
the in the same kind of aggro climatic
regions or in with the same kind of
varieties as well and and green
revolution so interestingly and and and
that's why you know we often called
Green Revolution as grain revolution
because it focused only on two crops
which was very important for food
security but it focuses only on rice and
wheat agriculture diversity a large
number of other crops have really paid a
price if you look at the third most
important which is pulses has has really
really suffered this is again a sort of
paradox where India is the world's
largest producer of pulses India is the
world's largest consumer of pulses and
India is also world's largest importer
of pulses right now we are almost in
that kind of in case of pulses we are
almost in that kind of a pre Green
Revolution era because as you will see a
large number of the country's efforts up
to about 80 to 83 percent of the
country's efforts now go only on two
crops rice and wheat this is to sort of
you know keep the revolution going you
know keep the hard on food security
moving and also because of the large
subsidies that the government offered to
the farmers to be able to grow rice in
weight and the large procurement program
that the government had to buy from the
farmers and once you make a political
promise it is very difficult to withdraw
from that so so about eighty percent of
the country's spending on agriculture is
actually going towards only two crops
and and therefore a lot of the other
crops are really suffering and
one of the biggest implication of that
is India has become food secure but
nutrition remains one of the biggest
challenge of the country so on one hand
we are talking about India being you
know one of the top most one of the top
seven agro producers of the world if you
look at the malnutrition level it hosts
the world's largest number of
malnutrition people as well so that
imbalance came from from extreme
revolution in in sorting out one problem
so I jumped the gun a bit I didn't know
this fly were coming so as you can see
malnutrition continues to remain a
challenge in a in India and a lot of
this is also you know do to those kind
of cereal based system interestingly if
we if we look at in in terms of crops
there has been three major policy pivots
in the country so far in the history of
independent India the first was the
Green Revolution the second was the fci
which is the food a Food Corporation of
India where the government was promising
procuring and buying from the farmers
the government would set up prices and
buy from the farmers because they saw
that the market was with the biggest
challenge for the farmer and they
started procuring from the from the
farmer and the third more recent one was
the food bill of India where the country
committed something like three billion
dollars a year and said we are promising
almost free extremely subsidized food to
at least sixty percent of the country
which was a very very ambitious plan it
became the world's largest public
distribution system plan so the three
the Green Revolution the fci and the
food bill of India all three major
reforms of the of agriculture in India
have focused
predominantly only on two crops rice and
wheat and we know that none of that has
really contributed to the malnutrition
challenge of the country so
interestingly if we look at you know
again as I said you know in a diverse
country like India where they where
there are such large number of wealth
quantiles it is very difficult to
generalize that you know so-and-so
village is more mal nutrient so-and-so
is not this quantile of health wealth
people are less mal nutrient and not but
if we look at these this this light
brown bar it kind of has a difference
between the top quintile which means the
wealthiest people of India and the fifth
being the lowest which is the poorest of
the poor of the country if we look at
the cereal consumption it is almost
constant across the entire quantile
which means the richest man of india and
the poorest man or a woman of india the
amount of cereals rice and weight that
they have access to there is not much
difference the differences comes in all
the diverse cities in the excess they
have two vegetables and legumes and meat
and so forth and therefore the problem
doesn't lie here and this this kind of
an even distribution and excess is a
huge success of green revolution but the
uneven success that came from non
cereals is a drawback of of Green
Revolution as well
in a country where as we know
fifty-three percent of the people depend
on agriculture there is a there is a
huge dependence on locally grown and
locally sourced food and therefore
agriculture and nutrition linkage in in
India is is at it's one of the strongest
in the world because because people
basically eat what they grow or what
their neighbor produces so again perhaps
as an implication of the White
Revolution or and also as a as a
by-product of country's economic growth
and income level changing the livestock
sector as i said is really making making
huge shifts if we look at the total
total output of livestock product in the
country it has it is more than all
grains combined and the livestock sector
again has grown almost on its own only
meeting the demand and farmers sort of
responding to the demand in the country
so if you can see the livestock sector
in the country is growing at the rate of
four point eight percent the the
agriculture sector is you know now at
2.8
however one of the impacts of white
revolution and the potential that the
dairy sector offers even today you you
know even if the livestock sector is
growing and because of the large number
large amount of money of the government
spend going into cereals and other
commodities as you can see the spend on
the livestock is very very little so
this is a sector that is growing double
then this sector this is the sector that
is employing now almost double number of
people then this sector and yet you can
see that the that the the policy or the
or the government spend is so much more
on on cereals and very little on
livestock among the livestock spend
eighty-seven percent of the livestock
spin goes on dairy sector India has a
large other sectors such as for example
the goat sector which is growing at the
rate of twenty percent right now 89 90
percent of the goat reading is done by
rural women landless rural women and
therefore yuge livelihood impact Rouge
rural development and social
implications to it however there is very
little policy attention to to that as
well and we have prioritized that as one
of our major investment areas and I'll
talk about that later
so recognizing that productivity is a
challenge I really wanted to sort of
brainstorm with you and say that you
know increase in productivity increase
in production in some of the crops is
not going to be the answer because
that's not what the farmers are looking
for also there are several things that
needs to be combined and and we have we
have you know historically seen that you
know our efforts in productivity and in
plant productivity has not really
realized to its full value mainly
because it has it has not been clubbed
with several other extremely important
factors that be the plant productivity
efforts needs to hit the ground one is
the extension you know having said again
you know reminding you that this is one
of the fastest moving countries of the
world this is one of the you know agro
leaders in the world and so forth if we
look at the the extension or or the
knowledge to the farmers the average is
40 which means only forty percent of the
Indian farmers have access to any
extension agriculture knowledge which is
this a this is one of the biggest
challenges right so technology
development is an extremely important
thing but you know with only forty
percent getting some excess to extension
knowledge or so forth how is the
technology going to reach to the firm is
going to be very very interesting if you
see the Indian RND system the the the
Indian Council for agriculture research
their rate is only eleven percent of the
technologies that they develop which I
think again still is an overestimate
from their side but let me quote them
eleven percent of the agriculture
technologies that they develop reaches
to the farmer rest all remains it's
mainly because of this gap
very interesting angle to how India has
changed is extremely fast feminization
of Agriculture you know in an economy
where of farm job opportunities are
growing where roads are being built and
constructions are happening everywhere
and urbanization is is moving very fast
and things like that agriculture more
and more is going is being taken over by
women farmers our policies our R&D
systems the products that we develop in
the labs are often not ready for this
change and there is a big mismatch
between between those those two things
you know from a policy angle there are
major change major challenges because
you know for a for a policymaker you
know somebody who owns the land is
considered to be a farmer so any of the
agriculture reforms or any of the
subsidy any of these things goes to
people who own the land women despite of
over forty percent of agricultural work
in India done by by women the total land
owned by women is less than five percent
in the country so there is a major major
challenge there if you look at the
extension services which I spoke about
earlier less than ten percent of the
Indian women less about forty percent of
the farmers have access to technology or
extension in case of women it is less
than 10 so these are some of the major
major pivots that the country is making
and and whatever efforts we do within
the country and from an international
angle will have to keep some of these
major factors in mind
I just wanted to very briefly talk about
the end user or the client of the plant
breeding efforts for example the the
efforts that we make from in an
international lab or so forth ultimately
I think it is very important to know who
the client is and where it is going
right I mean if we look at all these
numbers that you see are the average
number of a farmer in Bihar so this is
this is not made up numbers these are
real state level averages that they have
so if you look at the farm income it is
thirty dollars per month this is the
average income people make out of the
out of the farm and and if you if you if
you look at the consumption patterns
about thirty percent of what people
produce is used in the in the family and
rest whatever is there is used for
generating income out of it so if I see
from a farmer's perspective what happens
is let me let me take an example of a
dairy farmer because there are there are
no dairy but if I look at the example of
this farmer's cow right about seventy
percent of the money that I need to
spend on that cow goes in buying feed or
you know in feeding the animals okay now
more I spend on the agriculture input
less is my margin on the profitability
right and therefore that is fundamental
reason why the farmers adoption rate on
agriculture technologies such as seed I
mean new seeds new braider a breeder
varieties animal health you know agro
inputs are less because of course there
is no appetite because you're you're
that that margin between between how
much you are spending to produce your
your crop or livestock and how much you
are earning from that is getting lower
and lower and
that's fundamental reason why technology
adoption becomes such a huge challenge
so just wanted to map the major
constraint this is again a farmer's
perspective to what are the major
constraints in agriculture okay what you
know every single day 2000 people leave
farming in a country like India in a
predominantly agriculture country like
India 2,000 people are leaving farming
right and the main reason is we see it
from a Productivity angle we see from a
climate change angle we see from lot of
angle for a farmer there is only one
reason that there is no profitability
and I can make more money constructing
ugh somebody's house right and so so
that's that's the reason that's the
predominant reason now if we look at
from a farmer's perspective these are
the farmers key challenges in
agriculture why they think that you know
it is becoming very difficult for them
to farm if we look at from a
Productivity angle where a lot of the
government and a lot of RND focuses
these are the only two things which are
related to productivity rest are all
mostly non-farm nothing to do with
agriculture kind of kind of factors you
know market related and N and so forth
India is one of the largest investors in
agriculture in its it spent something
like 22 billion dollars on its
agricultural sector which is one of the
largest in developing world however if
we look at where that money is going
these the sizes of these these circles
represent and it is it is it is from an
analysis of of all the different
government programs and government
schemes the largest amount of money is
going in crop production now if you if
you can please remember the previous
slide and look at the farmers perception
this was a very very small part of the
challenge that they were saying the
major part of the challenges was X
attention where the weather is very
limited effort so there is a there is a
major mismatch between between the whole
whole puzzle and and therefore when we
say R&D you know technologies are
extremely important but but I would
really like to see technologies not just
from a crop productivity or production
angle but I would like to see it from a
slightly wider angle to talk about what
are the various technologies that one
can use for example market access for
nutrition and so forth and I mean market
access for example you know having all
these challenges I spoke about the Bihar
farmer and their challenges despite of
all those challenges and despite of
earning only thirty dollars from
agriculture the other fact about Bihar
also is eighty-six percent of the
households in Bihar which is one of the
poorest states eighty-six percent of the
households in Bihar have access to a
cell phone now and so how do we use
these opportunities to complete the
whole picture and so that our
productivity effort also really really
you know realize in their value and and
farmers you know even if the government
effort may be very little in these
things because it is a farmers priority
you know they put in so much it is it is
interesting I was talking to you about
the the goat project that we have this
is a this is a goat project in Bihar
where a very very large number of women
farmers who are growing goats we have a
program with them where we do the whole
value chain development animal health
and everything and it was fascinating to
see these women on their own absolutely
zero credit to our foundation or our
investment or anything because we were
focusing mainly on the animal health
aspect and all that completely on their
own they started taking pictures of
their goat with their little cell phones
and uploaded it on the ebay like Indian
site which is OLX which is an ebay like
Indian site and sold their goat as far
as about 700 800 kilometers away and the
women who sold their go there there the
price that they go they got for their
for their goats selling it far from that
ebay side was was higher anywhere
between twenty to thirty seven percent
so you know looking at constraint but
looking at some of these opportunities
and how they can use it and you know
very interestingly i was i was doing a
seminar at Oxford University and must
have said something like this and
somebody challenged but how can you say
that because you know there is there are
so many states in India where you know
electricity is such a problem how can
you think that you know and I I frankly
didn't have an answer to that and I went
back and we spoke to our field people
and things like that if we look at a
place like orissa there are rural
entrepreneurs who have now developed
what happens is on a bicycle they have a
solar panel the the young fellow goes to
a village and he's in the village for
four hours everybody gets their cell
phone charged he charges some sixty
scent or something for cell phone he
goes to another village he gets and then
he comes back to this village every two
day so every two days you can get your
cell phone charged fully right amazon
for example you know there was a there
was this thing about you know can we
sell seeds through amazon and some
people thought oh my god how naive right
i mean who is going to buy seeds through
amazon there are rural entrepreneurs in
places like Jharkhand and other states
and this is happening in Africa as well
where they go to a village with their
little little laptops the people gather
around them they order things online it
could be a plastic bucket it could be
seed it could be whatever children's
clothes the entrepreneurs order it
online then they go back and after ten
days whenever they come back they
they're things with them so there is a
huge rural market opening it does not
limit itself from whether you have
internet connectivity or not you don't
have to have a computer at home to be
able to order through amazon you don't
need to have electricity to be able to
charge your cell phone so there are
endless possibilities so I think looking
beyond just the productivity and
production lens to technology
development looking at some of these
areas and and that's what I just wanted
to you know breeding for profitability
and not just productivity I think is is
an important aspect the reason I i put
these three points down this morning is
because i am cognizant of the of the
international audience i'm speaking to
right when we at the foundation were
revisiting our india investment strategy
one of the questions that we constantly
asked ourselves and Brantley my my
colleague is here from the foundation
also we kept brainstorming on this and
said what is it that our small
foundation like us do in a large system
like India which invest 22 billion
dollars what is it that we can do that
the country is already not doing right
and thence when we came up with some of
these things as to what are what are
those value adds that weekend we can
bring in when there should be focused so
breeding for profitability would be one
idea I wanted to bring breeding for
mixed farming and I have an example of
that and and what I mean when we breathe
for a crop keeping the mixed farming
system in mind where we know that you
know sixty percent of the of the
animal's farm animals are fed with crop
residue and not by feed that is bought
from from a shop breeding for dual
purpose which is which is increasing the
food value of it also but also looking
at the feed value because the feed the
animal is equally important to that crop
farmer
is this and therefore looking at it from
a form of mixed farming lens rather than
a then just a crop lens or a livestock
length oh sorry and my last point there
was on nutrition I think you know
nutrition in both ways in the in the
existing rice wheat system around the
world how do we sort of fortify that and
how do we make that more nutrition
because we know that it is not really
contributing to people's nutrition lead
how do we how do we augment and
value-add there is one area and the
second thing is also about you know
diversification something simple like an
early early harvest late sowing rice
variety for example where a farmer gets
one hole full season in between to be
able to grow legumes for example you
know so so nutrition in from from many
many angles oh so keeping all that in
mind you know the foundation has been
investing in India since 2007 and we've
had a large number of investments they
were they were interestingly like any
other investments were very production
productivity oriented investments and
we've learnt a lot from those we last
year we decided to completely change and
revamp our agricultural investment
strategy in India to respond to and to
leverage on the government spending and
so forth and what we you know rather
than looking at it from a science or
from a Productivity only lens we we see
that whatever efforts we make in India
should be able to contribute towards
three things income and not just
productivity productivity as a means to
achieve that income but productivity not
as the end and so farmers income
nutrition especially the what we call it
as food system whereas
culture and nutrition comes together and
we have a large program here with
Cornell University as well on on that
and of course keeping the women farmers
in mind
of course I mean you know given given
the large of geography we decided to
focus on a few things and learn from
that and take it to other states yeah so
at the end I wanted to say you know it
would be good to take a sort of a
holistic view and not just look at it
from an R&D perspective RND to do what
is the question that we should be asking
ourselves and we could perhaps you know
ride the elephant together in Ithaca
thank you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu